All right, let's get right into audience questions.
Uh, some really good ones this week.
First question, isolationism versus non interventionism.
This is a good topic.
Hey David, I hear lots of talk when people
discuss Trump's tariffs about isolationism.
Is this the same as non interventionism?
It is not.
And this is a really, really important distinction.
I am a non interventionist when it comes to
the United States using the military or using
other means to mettle in other countries,
whether it comes to being the world's policeman
when there is not actually a coalition, for
example, that is decided this is something
that the world is going to take on and it's
abundantly clear that that's what should be
done.
I am against the United States meddling in
the elections of other countries or in regime
change in other countries.
But I am not an isolation is because I see
isolationism as a much further step, which
is not only do we not get involved militarily
for the defense of a third country, uh, not
only do we not do all of the things that a
non interventionist would avoid doing, but
isolationists can also want to be isolationist
on trade.
Now, I believe in specialization.
I believe that given the drastically Annaik
unequal distribution of resources throughout
the world, which includes both, uh, resources
of all kinds, I mean plant and animal resources.
If you read Jared diamond's book, guns, germs
and steel, he outlines how it is not by chance
that some parts of the world became more successful
and earlier than others.
It is significantly related to the flora and
fauna that either did or didn't allow the
creation of agriculture, which developed food
surpluses, which allowed specialist to start
developing technology and culture and politics
and governmental type organizations, et Cetera,
et cetera.
So I'm not an isolationist when it comes to
trade.
Uh, I also, I'm not an isolationist when it
comes to dealing with refugee issues around
the world dealing with climate change.
If you are a pure and true isolationists,
you feel no responsibility to even consider
doing anything about refugee crises in other
places in the world.
As a non interventionist.
You might choose not to get involved militarily
in what may be taking place in some other
countries, but when, what those circumstances
do is generate refugees as a non isolationist
but non interventionists you can say here's
my how my country is going to get involved
in helping refugees for example.
Isolationism can also lead to very extreme
immigration policies for example, which I
don't favor.
So there are some really important differences
between being an isolationist and a non interventionist.
I consider myself a non interventionist who
sees military action as the absolute last
resort, uh, to be used only in very particular
circumstances.
But I am the last thing from an isolationist.
And then lastly, I mentioned climate change.
Right now the pollution, climate change disaster
that we are dealing with goes completely beyond
country borders.
And isolationism is also a way to, in a sense,
bury our heads in the sand if it wants to
be used this way and say, you know, we're
worried about our country, we don't care about
pollution going elsewhere even though we have
to deal with pollution coming here from other
countries because pollution doesn't respect
country lines.
So I think isolationism is an absolute disaster.
I think non interventionism is very much in
line with the social democracy, a philosophy
that I sort of by and large subscribe to.
Let me know if I'm missing anything or if
I'm getting anything wrong or if you simply
disagree with my conclusions.